park landrais cette visite d' emmanuel
macron c'est plus un coup de com de la
récupération ou les bienfaits de sa
méthode
expliquez aux français je vois pas trop
quelles seraient les bienfaits de samba
do quelle serait sa méthode en matière
de ou sur le cas précisément un pool
voile poule
il a semble-t-il tenté d'expliquer vous
envoyer ma méthode dans la loi travail
et tout ça voilà les bénéfices qu'on
peut en tirer dialogue national
sauf que voilà il ya la lcc tautologique
ce qui s'est passé à un poil tout n'est
pas lié à emmanuel macron n'est pas lié
au fait qu'il y soit les pendant la
campagne présidentielle
le fait qu'ils aient retrouvé qui s'est
trouvé un repreneur c'est parce qu'il y
avait une loi qui avait été très
critiqué y compris par emmanuel macron
quand il était au gouvernement qui se
disait que une entreprise qui cède ainsi
tu dois trouver un repreneur et c'est la
direction d'entreprise qui a qu'eux qui
a qu'eux qui a acquis et à appeler
énormément de potentiel repreneur
pourrait s'il en trouvait un il se
trouve que c'est le cas yeux monsieur le
caillou qui est dirigé vers karajan
anti-chars également qu'a décidé de
récupérer le site
donc je vois pas en quoi emmanuel macron
et pour quoi que ce soit dans le fait
que la récupération c'est la
récupération c'est de la com où il pour
ça il est très fort d'heure